We did it, guys!
We hit 50 MILLION, thanks to your help.
yeah.. we believed.
no thanks.
don't swear.. please..
52 million now... -_-
a what?
nah.. it isn't
Now I've never been done before ( ͡° ͜ʖ ͡°) No one's even close.
We believed.
No shit.. lulz..
then do it.. -_-
Yaay!He's deleting his channel *slowclaps*
say Hwa?
You know when you make a joke  but it blows up bigger than you've ever imagined?
Waaaait a minute.. what?
mmhmm..
*shia labeouf* JUST DO IT!
(Cue anger and relief about the joke)
We didn't take it as a joke.
no it wasn't
That was it. That was, th- that was the joke.
*generic point at audience done by celebrities*
♪Omg I'm a retard.. Omg I'm a retard.. gimmie a life. ♪
♪ Whatever I said is a clickbaity joke to get more views. ♪
♪I've been a retard a lot ♪
♪Senpai please teach me how to kill myself! ♪
♪ Omg I'm a retard.. Omg I'm a retard gimmie alife
that wasn't original subs.. we subbed so that you delete your channel.
*not
lolol 60 mill+ now, boiis